la provincia de sindh en pakistán
afronta las drásticas consecuencias
humanitarias de las peores inundaciones
en la historia del país este salón de
bodas convertido en campamento médico
ante la demanda ante urgencia de
residentes locales atiende diariamente a
centenares de personas enfermas por las
inundaciones
comenzamos este campamento médico
gratuito hace cinco días esto es
gratuito
proporcionamos cánula y goteo ya que la
mayoría de los pacientes que vienen aquí
sufren de diarrea malaria fiebre alta y
problemas de la piel en nuestro
departamento de pacientes ambulatorios
de 5 a 6 médicos tratan de 700 800
pacientes diariamente sin costo alguno
la infancia es la población más
vulnerable desde que comenzaron las
intensas lluvias hace meses de los más
de 1200 muertos causados por la crisis
ambiental casi la mitad son niños muchos
de ellos mueren por las afectaciones a
su salud por la subida de las aguas que
causan infecciones cutáneas y digestivas
esto se suma al riesgo de malnutrición
las familias de sindh incomunicadas por
vía terrestre han necesitado de la ayuda
internacional para acceder a alimentos
este cultivador da una dimensión de la
catástrofe
hubo una pérdida del 100% para nuestros
cultivos no se pudo salvar ni nada en lo
que respecta a los cultivos el arroz el
algodón las verduras y las frutas han
sido destruidos un tercio de pakistán
está bajo el agua afectando a 33
millones de personas este año ha llovido
más que el promedio en 30 años un rostro
del cambio climático